[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage diane is with us hi
diane how are you i'm great i'm excited
well we're so honored to have you where
do you live i live in charleston west
virginia oh very nice town very cool
well welcome to nashville and all the
way here to do a debt-free scream yes
sir how much have you paid off i paid
off
seven
31
eighteen dollars and thirty one cents i
love it how long did that take you
thirty six months good for you and your
range of income during that time i'm on
social security in a small pension i've
uh
was between nineteen and twenty thousand
dollars
per year per year and you paid off
thirty two thousand and thirty six
months how did you eat
god god provided i'm telling you man
oh my goodness so what kind of debt was
the 32 000 well it was a personal loan
it was
some medical
credit cards
and
um what else did that that's good enough
good job well it's a good thing my
mortgage oh your mortgage right off your
house
oh yeah there's that
looking at a weird lady i love it no
house mortgage
way to go very cool all right so you are
100 debt free i'm debt-free how long has
it been since you were 100 debt-free
i've never been debt-free i was never a
natural saver i
raised my two daughters
alone
and
i spent you know what i needed to spend
i didn't yeah i just wasn't so you're
right so you're a retired single mom
right and uh how old are your daughters
well my my oldest daughter has passed
and my
youngest daughter's here with me today
she's going to be 50 next month awesome
very cool what'd you do what was your
career
i worked as a an accountant uh or
accounting
uh clerk yeah bookkeeper and so forth
yeah i worked for blue cross and blue
shield for years okay good and that gave
you the money to raise those kids and
and here you are retired and only thirty
two thousand dollars and you knock it
out knocked it out so what happened 36
months ago because this is a big change
for you
well 36 months ago um
wasn't the beginning of my story was was
in 2016.
i got a call from my granddaughter that
lives in wisconsin
my daughter's daughter
and she
told me
that her mom was in the hospital
and i had no i had no savings or
anything i couldn't get to her
my oldest daughter was
a kidney failure in the hospital in
charleston at the same time
and i had no way to get to wisconsin
and
i called my church and some friends from
my church and asked them to pray to for
some kind of solution for i didn't know
what to do
so they uh
they rallied around and come to my house
and gave me money to
get to wisconsin to see my daughter
because i didn't think she was going to
make it she was in a coma and i didn't
think she was going to make it
if i wanted to see her i
had to find a way so
my church rallied around me and you know
got gave me the money then my grandson
was there and he he drove me we didn't
have time for a plane so he drove me the
way all the way wow
so wow
so then that was that's a that's a
poignant wake-up call yes it is so
you're saying i got to do something i'm
not going to be in this position again
right never again so then
my oldest daughter passed in 2017
and so i was i was just an emotional
wreck
so i had to i had to do something to to
go through the grieving process and you
know get over her situation
too and
it just uh
i didn't know what to do so
i've
i started with uh
essential oils and
you know just to
help me emotionally and it and it really
did i felt like it really did but
i went gung-ho with it and overboard and
put it on a credit card and just run
myself you know into debt and then how
did you get connected to us well
a friend from church had
uh and i think in 2015 they put
a financial peace class at the church
but at the time i
i didn't feel like i needed it or
they asked for a hundred dollars and i
didn't have a hundred dollars at the
time to pay for it so i didn't
i didn't join at that time but i
i knew
after
all this happened i knew who i could
contact so i contacted them and asked to
borrow their book you know that maybe i
didn't know if you all had a book you
know
to teach you how to do it or what you
know
so i asked for the book and
so i read it wasn't the total money
makeover it was the like a money book
i'm not sure complete guide to money
money yeah
so i read that and then
in uh july
of 2018
i was
i normally we had would have a cookout
with my oldest daughter but she had
passed and so i was alone at you know
that fourth of july so i i just got on
youtube once once i read that book i got
on youtube and started asking
about dave ramsey and all that
all that all that
how can i how can i get out of debt yeah
but i did pray i asked the lord you know
lord i need to get out of debt
and so
i started binge watching
uh
youtube
and your shows you are not the normal
demographic that ben watches youtube i'm
just telling you
i don't know
that would be your granddaughter i was
desperate desperate to get out of debt
and so i
i uh
i did uh ben's watch and went back and
just i don't know i heard you tell about
the first debt free scream and i thought
and then when i saw the debt freezing
scream i thought
this is the plan that i need i'm going
to do this and here are your players
that's so good you are
all right i'm going to do something that
would cause my mama to whip me
but i'm going to do it anyway because i
think you're precious oh boy are you
going to do it dave yeah i'm going to do
it okay i got to know how old you are
i'm 74. 74. i was 70 when i started this
and
in july of 2018. and the reason i wanted
to be inappropriate for those of you who
are listening we have the benefit of
looking at this beautiful lady but those
of you that are listening i want this to
get your highlighter out and say anybody
can do this and it's never too late
right because you're a walking you're a
walking billboard you're incredible
thank you you are amazing on 20 years
inspiring
you did this on no money yeah 19 20 000
bucks and you pay off 32 000 in credit
card debt from the essential oil thing
went bad and get the mortgage paid off
and everything else wow i'm so impressed
with you
the story about behind the mortgage
payoff when i first started
i only owed about six thousand dollars
and so i paid it down to like 2500 and i
was just you know
i'm a facebook junkie so i put it on
facebook that i i'm a high-tech lady
here yeah yeah absolutely i put it on
facebook that woo hoo i'm down to 2 500
on my mortgage and so my brother-in-law
that i hadn't seen for 30 years hadn't
talked to him because my husband and i
were divorced and said
you know we wasn't close or anything but
his wife had a facebook page
he wasn't
you know on facebook but he stalked her
so
he saw that and he said usually at
christmas time
he would find a family in the church or
something that he would give to
so he
i was in wisconsin that christmas
with my daughter and i got a phone call
that his wife would said my husband
uh
saw your
facebook page he wanted to pay it off
i don't want to run out of time you're
amazing thank you so much for being here
that's an amazing story you're an
impressive impressive lady thank you
all right it is diane in charleston west
virginia 32 000 paid off in 36 months
house and everything
retired on social security making 19 to
20 she did this this is an amazing lady
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream
three
two
one
wow
that came from the soul there